what we aim to do in artificial immune
systems is to steal or to borrow the
computation whatever type of computation
we find the immune system does and then
to copy that computation within a
computer system we go work with
practical immunologists to find out
exactly what the human immune system is
doing and the interesting thing about
this field is that immunology is a
science is also rapidly progressing so
our understanding of the human immune
system is evolving in time and therefore
the models that we build of the immune
system are also subject to change which
can give us fresh ideas on how to build
these immune systems for example when
the first artificial immune systems were
built in the early 1990s they were based
on a principle called the self non-self
principle this principle assumes that
the body can detect any cell or any
living entity which is non-self
which doesn't belong to self now this
was a really interesting theory and was
applied to computer security however it
emerged in immunology about ten years
later that this theory maybe wasn't as
true was what we thought there was
another theory called the danger theory
which came along modeling the immune
system is a really important step in
artificial immune systems as it gives us
our grounding for the systems that we
build now the human immune system is a
very complex very adaptive very robust
natural system which is what we call
decentralized so unlike the nervous
system which has a brain as a central
controller the human immune system
doesn't have this it's what we call a
decentralized system which has a
property called self-organization so it
has the ability to respond to threats
and to repair the body after a threat
has been detected and eliminated and it
does this through orchestrating
responses through a number of
types of cell and these cells all work
together and to aggregate ly protect the
human body from different threats the
immune system is really really clever
because it can remember past encounters
with threats and when it remembers these
it can generate responses really really
quickly the second time that's what we
call the primary and secondary response
and how it does this is through a
natural form of optimization where after
after a protein has first been
encountered the immune system can create
molecules which fit that protein exactly
so when it sees that pathogen again in
the future it can respond to it really
quickly so there's an interesting
computational property of optimizing
something to fit a potential invader the
negative selection algorithm with one of
the first artificial immune systems are
AIS algorithms that was published you
have some form of representation of your
data in feature space and feature space
is where you have an N dimensional hyper
space which is where you can map
attributes from a feature vector which
might look something like this
this is an example of a binary feature
with one two three four dimensions for
our example of negative selection
imagine we had a dimensionality of two
and what we do we initially create a set
of what we call detectors to cover this
feature space so we randomly put
detectives in our feature space like so
and what we do is we plot a little
region which we class as normal what we
then do in the algorithm is then delete
any of the detectors which touch our
defined normal region this leaves us
with a tuned population of detectors
which only detect
things that we have defined as not
normal because it's not in our
definition of normal we then take our
network data for example run this system
on our network so we plot these new
items and abnormal data is where you
have the anomalies touching the detector
within a specified detector radius so
this one here this one here in fact all
of these detectors apart from this one
have anomalies in them these points here
do not touch your detector and these
would be classed as normal for those of
you who want the mathematical details
this is often calculated using Euclidean
distance and that's pretty much the
negative selection algorithm so one
example of the use of negative selection
is in with is within computer security
for the analysis of system calls system
calls are the way in which a running
program interacts with the computer
system in the operating system and so
each running program generates sequence
system calls and what we can do with
negative selection is we can create our
feature vector from a library of
different system calls and English and
change the value for each system call to
1 or 0 depending on whether that system
call is there or not and we should be
able to find out whether the program is
behaving correctly or not through
analyzing these sequences of system
calls and we can do this by feeding our
feature vector of which system calls
have been used by that program to
negative selection to find out whether
that is normal or anomalous for that
particular program that we something
like ok you found that no
he's trying to instead of just saying
the fire is trying to do something
exactly so what you can see is whether
your programs are behaving as you
expected them to because if not it might
warrant some further investigation this
computer scientists we're not usually
known for our physical demonstrations as
our physics and chemistry counterparts
if this goes horrific ly wrong and a big
Ghostbusters no symbol through